well dear friends and
colleagues
um I'd like to start uh by the customary
but heartfelt thanks to our hosts Mark
Terin and Mary Cameron and their very
efficient staff for organizing this
Himalayas studies conference in Yale
it is an extremely great honor for me to
be here today and I'm looking forward to
meeting and hearing all the scholars
that have been gathered on the
occasion I would like more particularly
to express my pleasure and satisfaction
at being offered a platform to introduce
to such a distinguished audience a small
portion of today's creative creative art
scene in
Tibet in Tibet proper literature and
poetry are vibrant even under today's
harsh circumstances or possibly because
of today's today's harsh
circumstances literary are the
inheritors of 14th centuries of incense
incessant non-stop writing activity
films are obviously a much later
addition to the art
repertoire film started in Tibet proper
as late as in
2004 but much earlier in Exile and
outside TI
and I'm happy to have gangen here as the
other keynote speaker because he's a
representative of this earlier more
experienced group of Tibetan filmmakers
outside
Tibet in spite of this and and for a
variety of reasons I cannot go into
today neither poetry nor films get a lot
of scrutiny from Tibetan studies
Specialists or Himalayan study
Specialists as I hope I will demonstrate
today I believe that these two art forms
and other art forms are worth our
attention as they enable us to delve
into the Dynamics of creation under
heavy constraints and into the world of
intellectual or virtual world of lay
Tibetans endowed with strong cultural
capital when they address other Tibetans
who are similarly
equipped so today I will talk about how
Tibetan artists mainly poets and
filmmakers and to make it short have
been negotiating the representation of
the black tent the Abode of Highland
pastoralists in the light of the massive
wave of resettlement of herders in
contemporary China that has gathered
momentum in the last decade or even less
than that I will in my conclusion
reflect upon the social role that these
artists can fulfill in today's Tibetan
Society if
any so last Sunday as I was um doing my
usual survey of the Tibetan websites
that I've been in the habit of checking
every day for the last few years I came
across a very surprisingly Frank piece
of political opinion from a Tibetan the
author of
this uh paper was is called sh Jang he's
a student from Northwest National
minority uh Institute in Leno who has
been nurturing the most creative and
maybe
modernist uh Tibetan intellectuals today
he was detained in April 2010 for
publishing a magazine in which he had
invited several Tibetan writers and
students to express themselves and their
to give an an analysis on the 2008
Tibetan Uprising anyway he was released
four months later and he has taken he
has resumed his activity as
an analyst we should say
freelance um I checked again this
morning about 700 readers have been
clicking you have been looking at these
post
and that's quite a lot uh of quite a big
audience in six
days um because most posts that I can
read um on the internet Reed between 20
and 500 to all together after a few
months but this one has generated 700
you know clicks just six days so that
shows you the interest triggered by the
his paper so what does he say he says in
this piece of
opinion um he expr is his view about the
king railway station massacre in which
29 person persons not including the four
uh perpetrators were killed on 1 of
March this
year first he claims his doubts about
the attribution of the ACT to ugur
terrorist which is a link which was
immediately made by the Chinese
media and uh he adds that if it were
proven if it were to be proven proven
then the Chinese government should not
be too surprised due to the harsh and
discrim discriminatory policies that
wigor have been subjected
to um while their history offers proof
enough that they have enjoyed freedom
for many centuries from the springboard
from the weor case which we can see as a
which I interpret as a springboard he
switches to the Tibetan question and he
asks uh he goes on denouncing the
resettle policy targeting Tibetan as a
way to under undermine the Tibetan
Freedom Movement and to kill the spirit
of resistance to assimilation so his
words are for sure for all these years
the government has forced people from
Tibetan areas Etc to move to cities
which is the focus on of the paper uh to
let has let Chinese settle down in
tibetan areas has controlled our
nationality and the use and spread of
our writing has exerted control on
freedom of religion in brief this is a
long-term plan to weaken the freedom
momentum among Tibetans and wigor and to
wipe it out I don't know if you are as
surprised as me by
the um openness or frankness or
um directness of this piece of political
opinion it's quite unusual to find this
on the internet and usually doesn't stay
for a long time most of the time though
indictment of the Chinese State policies
come under the literary Garb of poems or
lyrical Pros or films and this is what I
will turn to
now but then a little bit of uh
background I I don't think you need to
see a map of where Tibet is how it is in
it is divided into well we have Nepal
specialist so how it is it is divided
into uh into um regions and provinces
and this is a clumsy super
impos
superimposition of the nomadic uh areas
in the Hall of Tibet so until
1950 um grassland resources were
Community Based and they were managed in
a traditional way uh I won't go into
that uh then in the
1950s uh the ccp's people uh Tibet
people oh sorry the ccp's people
Liberation Army came to Tibet and
implemented gradually State and
provincial level policies so um Eastern
Tibet where most of the authors I'll be
talking about today and I think it's no
coincidence Eastern Tibet nomadic areas
uh were forcefully incorporated into a
new state and new political logic they
were collectivized there was massive
Uprising which is still understudied in
1958 in amdo uh the Northeast part of
Tibet and it um provoked a large scale
traum up on Tibetans there then in post
60s all over Tibet communes were settled
told established so this shows you it's
not exactly we don't have visual
representation for what happened then
but this comes from the Tibet mirror a
Tibetan newspaper which was published in
Kalen pong in uh and um which shows the
bombing of a chachang monastery
1956 and then Tibetan herders Tibetan
pasture land were incorporated into the
Chinese State and administration and
which was supposed to bring Liberation
and progress and I don't think I need to
go into DET details about that then uh
came the cultural revolution the end of
the cultural revolution U and in the
1980s uh communes were
dismantled U collectivization was
stopped and people were giv G families
were given what is called uh household
responsibility
system uh so it's not exactly a return
to pre-1950s hering organization
practices but uh it Tibetan herders
returned to a mode of living which was
closer closer to what they had known
before the 1950s there were few
Innovations like winter houses year
round habitats and F fencing of pasture
land I don't need to go into details now
I'm going to go into the the heart of
my my presentation so in the 1980s 1990
Tibetan language literature uh when you
read poetry poems novels all you you
found quite a lot of references to
Grassland pastoralism herders and black
tent but it was uh they had no special
status it was like an I call it infra
ordinary artifact and the grassland too
as well as the tent was an infra
ordinary
background moreover it was either
celebrated as an ethnic marker of an
authentic way of Tibetan life especially
for Tibetans who hail from these areas
or it was seen as the place where
nothing happens as we will see
or it was condemned as the Locust of
backwardness and
ruthlessness uh with many clan feuds and
vandas which Justified State and Chinese
Communist Party intervention and use of
legitimate violence for instance for
those of you who are familiar with
Tibetan uh contemporary literature one
of the first short stories that got to
be published right after the cultural
revolution uh is by the very famous tund
gel um who died in 1955 and tund gel
wrote a short piece uh called J Tang the
plane of the wild yak and the tiger
about rivalry between two uh neighboring
um nomadic
groups um a young man from one group a
young woman from another group fall in
love it doesn't please it doesn't happen
to please the elders and their fight uh
because um the tel was trying to promote
um free well um to to to no sorry to um
denounce forse marriage and to show the
backwardness also um the backwardness of
Tibetan Nomads and Tibetans in general
when it comes to love and the story ends
with the intervention of the local
Communist Party secretary I would call
it a communist happy hand when uh which
was almost compulsory at that time in
the publication in the early
1980s so that's here's one little piece
of poetry by the way we will be reading
some poetry translated into English uh
quite a lot during this presentation so
um this um poet poem was written one day
in the tent in 19 was published in 1994
might have been written before that was
written by Jang Jang is one of the
foremost Tibetan uh caders highly
educated in tibetan uh history and
language and I will slow more rapidly
talk about him a little bit later
because he would come back in the topic
in the
talk what did Jang write in his poem uh
so it's like one day in the tent the
meadow has put on its clothes yellow
specks of smoke have fallen slowly on
the extraordinary accounts of the upper
community community Lama and the D of
the community below grandmother's Prayer
Will neither slows down nor accelerates
it turns and turns again in the Serene
and solitary moment a slight boredom
escorted by the snow dots the ropes and
scatters on the ground
the head of the family concludes the UT
trim on tundup so's garment is two
fingers longer than that of the on her
Elder
sisters the old herders tired snoring
follow each other and increase by the
hour so what do we what picture do we
get from this one day in the tent boring
boredom snoring old age slowness
futility of daily concerns and
conversations uh pettiness uh they
dominate the poem of
jesang and it's it represents quite well
the mood uh or the way how the way how
the the tent and the nomadic environment
was rep represented
then but then things accelerated in the
19 in the 2000 um there were many new
reforms economic social reforms uh which
I won't go into detail here but just you
know this this is to give you just an
idea of how the um hering communities
were
affected strongly affected by um ensuing
policies uh aiming at resettling them in
per semiurban uh settlements as you can
see
here so on the part of the Chinese State
uh you can if you look at the official
publication
um everything is you know has improved
Tibetans now live in a beautiful and new
area which is nice and cookie cut it
looks much neater and nicer and cleaner
than uh the previous camps of the of the
nomads and um if you read whatever is
being published in um in officially in
China today um you know you will find
that there's an agreement in the way
that uh nomadic
life and um was represented in the 1980s
and '90s by Tibetans themselves in their
literature and the way that it is being
represented now in the official
Publications uh
slowness
uh
backwardness uh cut being cut off from
contemporary reality these are the
topics that are recurring
but then we reach what I call chapter 2
to the best of my knowledge and I may be
wrong but the uturn in terms of
representation of herding and the black
tent can be dated to 2006 quite
accurately that year the very same
author whom uh I just mentioned
jesang who was born in a nomadic area in
1960s he graduated from Central
Institute of foreign nationalities he
has a master's degree from High
nationality Institute so he was he's
among the Highly Educated Tibetans of
his generation he's the director of the
nationality section of the golok
prefecture translation Bureau so he has
a high uh State position and he has
published many books and
poems so here he is on the left
jesang uh
published uh a six-page text of a highly
highly literary Pros in the dchar
magazine which which is a
wellestablished official literary
magazine published in chinai
Province I must confess that I did read
it at that time or a little bit later
but I think I was completely unable to
grasp the the meaning that was hidden
behind this text or not hidden as much
as not available to me I couldn't
decipher what he meant meant at that
time and the text does make a lot of
sense a few years
later um
so what does he say in his text called
farewell to the tent he's witnessing
with disbelieve the farewell to the
black tent so he says that's how it
start I give absolutely no Credence to
the rumors that you are going away now
leaving Tibetans where they are I give
no more credit to those who say that
you're going to leave us by breaking
your ropes without even an announcement
to the Land of
Snow you will definitely go you're
already moving away the big ones are
moving with jerks the little ones are
moving with humility they are
disappearing one after the
other his writing is highly emotional
it's quite lengthy it's six page long
it's very lyrical and it shows a strong
symbiosis between Tibetans and their
tent oops
sorry so here's I you know I just show
you a few since the blood of Tibetans is
mingled with you tent the joys and
Sorrows of Tibetans are united with
yours the destiny of Tibetans is one
with you and you are the Tibetans have
offered the same prayers in the land of
Snows this is why no love is stronger
than the love I feel for you and no
commitment is higher than the commitment
I hold for
you um we can read in these six pages
which are to my
feeling anyway extreme beautiful the
hint at the imperative of modernity as
possibly one main cause Behind The
Parting of the tent or the fire the the
the farewell to the tent you must
definitely quit this world at the
crossroads between old and new eras and
when you will have finished your long
wandering in the highlands is it true as
they say and we can wonder who is this
they that you will become a pretty tale
like the happenings of
old and although the the
um the text is very it's quite emotional
um it's more love feeling that exudes
from the text and not so much uh the it
seems to me the inner feeling of the
narrator but if you they are transposed
on the on the tent when you are going
where are you going with this sad look
so why are you living in fear why should
I accompany you unwillingly and this is
when he gives his opinion about the uh
the leaving of of the
tent
um
sorry so as you can see his
representation of the black tent and
nomedic community of course you haven't
read the whole text but I have and I can
guarantee that his uh gaze upon gaze
upon the tent has completely changed
from a dull inmoral artifact he has
become a conflict-free idealized organic
ho with which the narrator I guess it's
Jang enjoys a perfect relationship in
which Bens live a conflict free
harmonious enlightened
existence he doesn't clearly uh explain
to the reader why the departure of the
tent is irreversible although it says it
is and you can understand that it's very
unexpected the narrator keeps feeling um
surprised and asking the tent why it is
living um it looks almost maybe when I
first read it I thought it was almost
like a natural disappearance I couldn't
grasp the meaning now I think I I
gradually understand uh why he didn't go
into
details um so for the sake of brevity I
will only focus now on nine poems that I
have been able to gather
online uh in in the last four to five
years and they only represent the tip of
the iceberg of poems which deal with the
black
tent
um
they show the same passion for the black
tent as jang's poem often anthropo
anthropomorphizing it addressing it
directly using honorific
language uh but they contrast in one
important thing with jang's poem because
they current they openly contest current
policies of
settlement and in spite of their formal
diversity I have been struck to find a
number of sim similar themes from one
poem to the other most poems are are so
loaded that it's often difficult to
isolate one or two little lines and one
theme of its own so I will try to give a
few topics that are recurrent from one
poem to the other for you to uh to get a
flavor so something which is striking is
that these new poems let's call them the
new poems um often resort to childhood
memories childhood memories is not a
very widely practiced literary genre on
the part of Tibetan writers so why we
can ask we can we may wonder why they
resort to this in the case of that of
the tent well most writers have spent
their childhood under the tents but this
is not enough I think it gives a a
pretense of authenticity of intimacy and
it's also it's based on emotions and
more than on analysis so it can be
shared by many
readers uh
which which who can relate to um to the
text more easily so jesang actually I
have to quote ju kesang here because he
also use resorts to childhood memories
or the narrator's childhood memories it
is under the skirt of your robe that my
little body fell gracelessly among men
it is your shelter that my hesitant
little legs first explored surfing on
the waves of the samsara is also inside
you that I my small Mind through the
first lassos of its gaze hurt pounding
heart pounding and then a more recent
one one night as I lay between my dad
and mom waiting for sleep I looked at
the sky sorry I looked at the stars
twinkled through the star hole in the
roof and felt that everyone was moving
swiftly every one of the Stars was
moving swiftly like the eyes of children
who cannot fall asleep I wandered into a
dream as I was as I listened to my
father tell me the story of the poor
youth youth and the Rich Young maiden
and this generated many comments on the
internet how this these these few lines
had provoked made emerge a lot of warm
feelings and nice childhood memories in
the minds of the readers ah I
won't so apart from these childhood
memories we have more um contentious
content first I can read in most of the
poems a questioning of the need for
settlement to begin win with and the
means that are used to settle people so
here's kaing ch when I sit by the table
and reflect the strings of my Brethren's
biographies un tied biographies of all
size I do not see their backs shivering
and shriveling in the call of the
Tempest I do not see their cheekbones
cracked and red in the cold of the
blizzard I do not see the fear in panic
in their eyes every dark and rainy night
uh so one of the rationale of settlement
is to improve comfort in uh we under a
proper house in a proper house and this
is being questioned by CH bagu who whom
we will meet a little bit later
bagu uh says that grassland owes its
beauty to the castle the cattle and Men
owe their longevity to the tent so long
life is things can be uh attributed to
living under a tent not medicine not
science uh is the adequation between man
and his environment that uh provokes
longetivity and he he also has um a a
short a very small hint at the
education into accepting uh the
rationale behind the
settlement education that was given to
National members of nationalities of
course here we mean he means Tibetans
and he says nationalities have been
educated for 14 years pain and suffering
have suffused suffused my heart for just
as long uh so as you can see there's a
strong resistance on the rationale and
reasons given for the uh for the
resettlement many authors also question
the quality of resettlement housing uh
here's bonu again he's a teacher by the
way I was born in a Tibetan Valley I'm
content with a mountain a river and a
forest I was born in a little dark tent
a pole and a beam are warm enough the
stone and Earth house was traded to us
but in the slightest earthquake it is a
killing machine so this um uh this issue
of the fear of the house that might
collapse above your head is present in
many poems it can be of course linked to
the fact that Tibetans and Nomads are
not used to sleeping under tents it can
also be a hint to the poor quality used
as materials for building the uh the
houses um not only that but the
consequences you know the reasons the
actual uh making and the later phase the
consequences of development or
settlement are also they're often
intermingled uh this questioning comes
up in several poems uh here is our one
women women poet of the day kawal hamu
she's not the only one in Tibet but
she's she's quite strong on this topic
and here's what she writes it's a poem
called changes and she's being sarcastic
about you know changes supposed to be
development development is supposed to
be good and she's uh presenting her own
version of changes that have occurred in
her nomadic settlement and she said
thanks to this Coal Mine a Macadam Road
Cuts straight across the center of the
community sister dr's leg got broken
Uncle tempal his life little tarlo
became an orphan uh she refers to lores
that P you know that go on the road very
often and do not pay attention to the
inhabit local inhabitants who are not
used to seeing these big trucks passing
by every day and bagu
again uh he's very sarcastic about the
consequences the many Greenhouse is
erected straight in poo plane which
where which is where he comes from uh
mean herders do not have to her their
cattle in the mountain any longer and
now all of them have begun to spend
their life joyously singing merry songs
their life joyously talking idly and now
all of them have begun to spend their
life joyously drinking
alcohol which is uh a fear that many
Tibetans entertain about uh alcoholism
being uh spreading in these settlement
areas uh so this just a big not only not
really the beginning but many problems
are being raised in these uh in these uh
poems uh environmental issues of course
is a big
question
so Nako 2012 once in Town wait for death
in the chemical Breeze wait for death
while fearing earth water fire and
wind uh n oh dear black tent is it true
that in the land that was ours and I
won't you know go into too much detail
about the land that was ours which is
quite eloquent in that in the land that
was ours we used to drink from
uncontaminated rivers that and that our
mountains were unstayed by heaps of
dusts he refers to development projects
that contaminate water especially
mineral search for mineral
mining billu again little by little row
rows upon rows of houses of gray
shackles and later buildings have been
built upon kongur Mountain shoulder Ming
and amputating the mountain so we here
have the it's an living creature and
frightening away wild animals who once
teamed in the area but now are nowhere
to be
seen um another question that uh is
being raised often in this poem is the
new habitus how to make a transition to
new habitus as far as privacy for
instance and food as we will
see uh Upon returning from your ancient
herd Earth Camp sorry this is the
context you cross the bridge again and
arrive in a colorful white and red
Village someone sees you every day from
the multi-storied house painted in white
someone looks at you at all time from
the curtainless windows so the regime of
intimacy has changed and they have to
adapt uh yagu Patel 2010 I do not wish
to experience Joys and sorrows and
trusting myself Upon A Shack it's not a
house it's a shack for him thus I don't
want a house I don't want a locker I
don't want a key I will be content with
a small brown tent that can host the
wind and the snow as my
guests Napo 2012 go to the city go to
the city and feed yourself on grass go
to the city and feed yourself on bugs so
what does he mean here
um grass refers to vegetarian food or
non non meat food which uh can be part
of the diet of the Chinese people and
bugs is also refers also to small
animals that are being part of the uh
Chinese diet but not of the
Tibetans so this is an idea that the
city is Chinese and you get used to
eating Chinese
food and then you have a veryimportant
question the ultimate aim of this
settlement policy and in one poem menom
2012 what do we read when the wind is
freezing we can indeed light a fire in
the small room when the Rays of the sun
are scorching hot we can indeed welcome
the breeze in the little
Corridor is this house the making of the
two hands of God or and there's a space
the last toop before
death so um you may Wonder what uh what
death menome is talking about it could
be um it could be a hint to the soon the
the announced collapsing of the house
which seems to be a great concern and it
has to be due to the poor quality of
materials it can also be uh the decline
of uh this of this community uh living
in New in a new
environment or despair leading to death
it's not clear
um more even more interesting I think
the question the definition of modernity
by the by the use of uh quotation marks
Mao says pay homage to and be friend
with the modern prostitute and discard
Traditions so who has set the criteria
to decide what is modern and what is
tradition even Jang 2006 quite mellow in
his comment wres I'll B from letting you
go out of conservatism and in the name
of all habits so uh you know that
usually the Trope about Tibetans is that
there are con um Tibetan herders are
conservative and attached to tradition
so here you have these poet these poets
who question uh the very notion of what
is being
modern then you have many many many
references to
time um TI Tibetan poets make claims uh
often to recall the historic
historically sedimented memories
associated with the tent and its
location and one of the most recurrent
words associated with the black tent is
ancestor
um usually
when
the this mental like repetition of the
manyfold generation occupation of space
and therefore occupation of space by
oh sorry and then we'll see that sorry
uh just a second so here's the first
extract oh dear black T so he's
addressing the black I I wrote dear
because he uses honorific you know janak
La so oh dear black tent is it true that
long long ago the Clutter of our
conquering horses hooves Was Heard by
two-thirds of the world that the banner
of our Fame extended over the four
continents so his uh the the tent is a
witness to Glorious
past and uh enables them enable uh the
authors
to uh to claim occupation of space and
Mastery of space but actually uh there's
no such thing dear black tent what a
defeat has befallen us what an epidemic
has contaminated Us in the bend of a
century so he's talking about the early
2000s and here there's a small glimpse
of the future which is extremely unusual
and I return to that the hopes of 10
thousands of years have faded the once
familiar crowd strolling on on the bar
cor has changed obviously he's referring
at I guess Chinese tourists uh um
circling the bark or occupying the
Tibetan space in hassa the pure land of
the old woman's taale is gone nothing is
left but A Sky Full of black clouds and
a railway that venomous stake snake
sorry um and then space is also uh a
constant
uh concern of The Poets um bagu again um
writes about houseb building State
Building and state making he talks still
about his kangur CRA crack when he was
when he was born where he was born he
says at some point by the very thick
mountain by the very pure river by the
very lofty Meadow they began to erect
cotton tents with government inscribed
on them I think everybody understand and
a few years later they turned the cotton
tents into gray houses and a few years
later these gray houses became gray
Villages and a few years later these
gray Villages became gray sky
skyscrapers now the Pulu pooo plane has
described by my grandfathers is a lost
dream um there are ethnic hints in these
poems not that many some most of them
are um to be guessed by the by the
reader and here is an ironic view on
Chinese people by
bagu uh when the bus made a stop I
thought of Tibetans who going through
this crck would cast small wind horses L
along with
prayers I thought of Chinese who going
through this crack would cast their warm
pee with
joy so you have this desecration of a
Sacred Space due to the uh ignorance of
its value by alien
occupants it can be also exclusivist if
I may use this word uh in my nomadic
Community there are black tents not the
white cotton tents of the Muslims in my
Nom in my nomadic Community there are
black tents not the blue cotton tents of
Tina and Tina is Maha Tina is China in
my nomadic Community there are black
tents not the green cotton tents of the
army uh
and
finally you you have a feeling of
collective linguistic anxiety which
pervades the
poems once again bagu in car your CAG
although I found it hard to sing a
little song of Sal for myself I
prostrate it three times and say three
prayers for the sake of the prayer
flagpoles whose life force had not yet
disappeared in Sp in spite of the
blowing wind and in the land which still
Bears its own name in spite of the
movement of time uh here it's kind of
easily uh
decodable uh the life force uh the the
blowing wind are the changes of time uh
the movements of times are changes and
also the current policies and it refers
to the daming and renaming of many
Tibetan places by which China uh makes
State Tibetan territory part of its
territorial um
scope and jiaang was also in his 2006
plea to the tent uh
quite um specific about this and he
wrote and then Y and Z and katup and
Chad andu and we are the only ones on
Earth to master the numerous terms that
are specific to you the black tent so if
you depart from us without a backward
glance with whom will we use these terms
terms who will listen to us to to them
sorry so as you can see the mood in
tibetan poems is quite uh it's univo uh
there are there is not much contestation
much contest about critic you know
everybody's critic everyone is
criticizing the settlement process with
all that it entails so what about films
um I won't be showing me showing many
extracts film extracts for to you um
because I don't have that many films
available uh I can I will show you three
first we should note that the first I
referred to the first Tibetan film made
in Tibet dating 2004 and for those of
you who who know paten it's the first
film h a student film made upon
completing his studies at the Beijing
Film Academy and as it happened he chose
uh as a title and set prop for his uh
film um the
grassland so but this is to me iconic
Tibet for external cons consumption this
this film was not meant really for
Tibetans whereas the poems that we've
seen before are meant for Tibetan
consumption but okay maybe he set a
precedent anyway in the last since 2009
we've seen a flourishing amazing number
films made by Tibetans on the Tibetan
plateau uh low budget not always good
quality uh that take a nomadic
background as um as a core component of
the film so here are just a few I don't
think maybe you've seen these images so
much so I can show you just a few of
them and you see you know they always
put forward uh nomadic life
in
the in their presentation so two films
are of Interest D's film a film called
borim janak The Lost black tent uh I've
with I've put arrows and you can I don't
know if it's very clear but they point
at nomadic
settlements uh the guy who was to be a
hearder uh cries in despair looking at
this nomadic settlement and the last
scene shows him praying literally
praying and begging uh the black the
black tent to return he goes back to the
last place where his family set up the
tent and he almost cries and and cries
to the top of his voice shouts and calls
for the tent to come back of course it
doesn't come back I don't have I I was
trying to find it but for some reason it
has disappeared from uh uh all possible
uh websites that used to uh accommodate
dat or host it
um and then the one I can show you maybe
I don't know how much time do I have
left 20 minutes 10 minutes um I'm sorry
because my uh I have I yes here it is so
this is just to show you how the black
tent is shown in in these am semi
amateur Tibetan films and this is the
beginning of a film called s The Wailing
a
dust and I don't know if it has sound
should
have
so this is a story about uh revenge and
a sad love story Between Two Lovers in a
nomadic camp and the other one I can
show is the
promise uh which begins also with you
know views
of
grassland sorry the definition is not
very good
but
okay I will stop here it's just to show
you that a nomadic background features
prominently in many many films much more
than um it could be expected more than
half of the uh films show a nomadic
background and now I will and showing
you an extract of a film which is still
in the
making uh by duang so just a word about
dukar he's the sound editor for paten
the professional filmmaker who has
emerged from Tibet in the last 10 years
and he's starting to make he's a
musician he's making his own films now
and this is a documentary film that he's
been making for two
years it's about it's a it's a
documentary film had his own
grandmother and uh a cousin of his uh
the grandmother as well as the whole
nomadic Community to which they
belong uh is sure that her grandson who
who we will see in the film is The
Reincarnation of her late husband so
there are many hints many memories given
by the child when uh when he was just
about to to to talk many interviews of
the child of the of the young man who
remembers his his childhood neighbors
who says how it was striking that uh he
would remember his previous life so and
it's also about this transition between
this old grandmother who
still two minutes okay okay my God so
you just see for
yourself but the film I wanted to show
three
minutes
so this is the father of the of the
young boy and the mother and the
sister
for
e
and thus the film ends so it's a very uh
dull Prospect uh the life of this new
generation of Nomads who are said and
you can see that Guru cannot blow in The
Conch and um so I I have to stop
here okay I can I had six points of
conclusion so I just make
one so I suggest that uh the black tent
is uh just a
second what we can call an onomia so for
the Tibet predicting the fate of Tibet
is predicted through uh that of the
black tent and it represent Tibet and
and
Tibetans uh the first dis disappearance
of these black tents and the dadic
communities uh be they chronicled by uh
poem poets in words or by
filmmakers as in the case of duar serang
as you can see obviously does not
celebrate the end of this uh way of life
and the entry into a modern or developed
way of life but it's much to the
opposite the occasion of a
self-reflective analysis that boils down
to the fear of a similar fate that
awaits T Tibetans all of them farmers
urbanites and Nomads doomed by a type of
development they feel powerless to
counter and in its implementation and
characteristic and bagu writes quite uh
plainly discarding one's cattle and tent
is the port of the decline of the land
of snowa Tibetan Traditions are nearing
the end but not the flow of my Tears
which is still
long and maybe I can just uh stop here
uh quoting One Last Time jang's 2006
piece it might seem strange to a western
audience that he
linked uh the fate of the tent with that
of Tibetan language but I think this is
also one of the big anguishes or
anxieties of Tibetans and what is that's
the very last uh part final words of his
uh essay farewell to the tent and he
says promise me something please if I
come back here 80 years from now grant
me that I may call you by shouting out
your name three times and I also pray
that I will still be able to know how to
write in your name in tibetan so this is
I think with this I will wrap up my talk
and uh I have no conclusion because I
had you know a few more pages to go
thank you very much for our
attention fris please do if you're
willing to take a few questions um that
was an enormously poignant and moving
presentation I think for all of us
working in the region whether in the
Northern parts of Tibet or in Nepal
Bhutan Northern India uh many of these
themes are current in all the areas we
work in memory landscape belonging
language so with that I would like to
ask if there are any questions for Frise
we're eager to have a conversation here
and we have a couple of reving revolving
roving
microphones I'm really intrigued about
the use the number of the poems that are
coming through the internet and wonder
what you think the relationship between
poetry that circulates on the internet
and the the widespread of the internet
uh as as opposed to poetry or song or
things that people might be actually um
performing or circulating through other
ways uh internet has brought a huge
impetus to Tibetan language and um
the PE Tibetan people I mean this was
one of my this was one of my points is
that writing poetry is a you know way in
Disguise of writing social critics which
is quite obvious in the present
circumstance and it would just take
whole team of people scrutinizing the
internet every day to look at all the
poems that are being published online
and I have here if I may uh even
commentaries to poems are written in
Poetic style so here in verse
versification so because you know
there's a question that okay everybody
agrees there's no counter voice
everybody laments the death of the black
tent is there no one who who has a
different opinion and I found one so it
was in one comment number two in an era
when the world is developing and when
nothing surpasses Business Development
you and I brainless Tibetans are
clinging like a dead like a corpse to
the black tent that does not stop the
wind this is pointless so that was the
comment and it's it's versified it's you
you
know you know it's all versified it's
quite a common feature that they would
even reply writing poetry to com to upon
poetry so so it's poetry is a much more
widespread mode of expression even for
today's concern that it is in today's
world in the West for instance and
internet has really been a huge boom and
uh mobile phones as
well um I'm wondering if you've engaged
it all with the production of music
videos and the prevalence of grassland
image imy in music and how that is
present in tient's gathering with each
other and the music video always in the
background um that's something that I've
noticed the grassland imagery and the
tent imagery popping up and I was
wondering if you've engaged at all with
that I'm not that familiar with the
world of today's um modern contemporary
music but it's true that uh the
grassland image is prevalent I think
it's a way um of cultivating t
uniqueness because farming communities
there are plenties in Hunt China right
hering communities is completely and
heard of in a Han Chinese world so uh
Tibetans are trying to carve this space
for themselves to avoid at least
to um to not to avoid assimilation which
is you know beyond the carving or not
carving a pace for space for oneself but
at least showing their difference in a
very striking way and there couldn't be
more striking than a nomadic Community
this is one of the possible
hypothesis tietan unique culture I think
also the Tibetans are struggling with uh
rhetoric from the Chinese state with you
know China's characteristics China's
exclusive culture and these gave ideas
maybe to Tibetans they already have a
high idea of themselves as being quite
unique right on the top of the planet
and with Tibetan Buddhism but fa with a
state rhetoric that emphasis emphasizes
this point they are building up on this
as well and they try to what the
exclusive Tibetan
exclusiveness just like or
exceptionalism like Chinese are
currently uh discussing on a huge scale
Chinese
exceptionalism um first of all uh it was
very beautiful poetry coming out out of
just the black tent which is also very
very common in the mountains of my
country
Bhutan similar fate um the herders are
abandoning the the traditional black
tents but the big difference of course
here is that it is not in position it is
not because somebody else is telling
them to move somewhere else but rather
you know the the cheap tarp the light
blue tarp that that you now see dotting
the mountain sides m is much cheaper you
can you know a little child can pack it
up and take it when the family moves
whereas you know the bigger tent it
takes you know years to to weave is very
heavy and you know and as Farm labor as
more kids get educated they move out of
the mountains and they go to schools
families are left with less people you
know hurting their acts so so it's it's
a different parallel um I'm just
wondering how you know in in in the
Landscapes that you that you work in is
that a common common feeling that
everybody shares that you Lament the
loss of this this tent I mean it is
certainly beautiful and poetic and all
that um but mean in our case in in
Bhutan it's a slightly different
scenario you know we as Outsiders find
it sad that that now the mountains are
dotted with this ugly looking plastic
you know tarp uh however the the reality
of Economics the reality of of changes
in society is is demanding something
different so so again it's it's it's a
different parallel I I'm just curious as
to to from your U observations you know
whether is that if that's a common thing
that you see across or is there also a
big section of that that society that is
saying let's move on you know as well so
I mean certainly different yes you have
made several points here um first um
it's true that there's a kind of
ambivalence on the part of the authors
because they all came from this
background and they've all left it so
it's easy to lament the loss of this
background uh once you have left it um
the other thing is and I wanted to quote
Emil's um I think catchphrase uh it's I
think as you said the background is
different and to me it's a ref refusal
or reluctance on the part of Tibetans to
accept uh the the gift of development a
chinese-led development so uh were it as
in Bhutan I guess on a voluntary basis
and it it is in sometimes uh it has been
in Sometimes some occasions um it might
not trigger so many poems it's it's
just it is the it crystallizes the big
anxiety of seeing not only as I said the
black tent or nomadic communities
disappear but the language the language
meaning the Tibetan nationality altoe
Tibetans so uh it's it's like an excuse
to talk about politics without talking
about politics and it's an excuse about
being powerless on your own territory
and having to go through a development a
development process that you have no
word in you have no saying
in thank you franois so much for such a
beautiful and Powerful talk um with all
of this with with all these beautiful
descriptions of the Black Yak hair tent
I kept thinking of the other kind of
tent which is the white cotton tent yeah
which I associate maybe wrongly more
with Central toed and with like Garden
parties and picnics and things like that
and I wonder if that's an image that you
find it all in the literature that
you're looking at not at all so that has
no no kind of cache at all in no you see
here in one of the poems that I quoted
It's associated with the Muslims and I
think it's because of the white and the
whiteness and the white cap that they
wear because I don't think Muslims have
uh white tents anyway as far as I
know uh so it would be more like the
association of the color uh but they're
not they don't celebrate this tent as
much as uh uh the the black
one a final question perhaps Cara um
thank you Fran this has been absolutely
um I mean just very fascinating the the
question I have is where uh are the
animals in all of this and it was more
um evident when you put up the films and
then we saw yeah and and but in the
poems um is there a romantic lament or
an elegy also for The Disappearance of
of of animals and I'm thinking also kind
of in the context of Exile in many of
the interviews that I've done I get a um
a real loss and Nostalgia and yearning
for horses um so I don't know
necessarily where which animals might
appear in the Poetry but I guess I was
wondering if you could speak to that it
just seems so specific the the elery
again for for the tent um and where do
animals appear they they often they
often mention uh the yak hair from which
uh the tent is made and the the
wholesome of the process you know Yak
tents Yaks roaming on the territory and
and their
hair creating the tent but they don't
talk about so much about the cattle
that's a very good point I never thought
about it but Pen's last film called old
dog is really an interesting film on the
symbiotic relation between dog and sheep
and people you know it's the Mastiff uh
the big dogs and how it has become a
market upm market um Novo accessoire and
accessory and it's all around the
relationship between the man and the the
animal and I think it's quite new as far
as I know in uh art production at least
films
production on that note and I realize
that um I'm in the awkward position of
breaking up the wonderful discussion
that we're hoping to have this day but
some of you may be nostalgic for coffee
and I'd like to thank f for a deep
probing and challenging presentation
that has got all of us thinking what a
wonderful way to start fad thank you
thank
you